[Musique]
rebonsoir à trois jours du premier tour
dernier instant donc pour rééquilibrer
les temps de parole des candidats sur
les radios et les télés oui depuis le
lundi 28 mars minuit et jusqu'à ce
vendredi à minuit c'est le temps de la
campagne officielle et durant cette
période toutes les radios et télévision
sont contraintes de suivre la règle de
stricte égalité du temps de parole et du
temps d'antenne imposé par l'art comme
l'Autorité de régulation de la
communication audiovisuelle et numérique
une égalité stricte à respecter à la
seconde près objective donnée exactement
la même exposition à chaque candidat
alors autant dire que c'est un véritable
casse-tête pour des chaînes comme la
nôtre mais on s'y est appliqué jusque là
et on relève une nouvelle fois le défi
ce soir avec Florent Rodot bonsoir
Florent alors on a l'habitude d'entendre
votre voix sur le récap politique du
jour et ce soir on va faire une sorte de
récap politique donc incarner en plateau
et ces derniers jours Florent comme tous
les 5 ans on parle beaucoup de votes
utiles
que certains électeurs ont pris au pied
de la lettre voyez donc ce bulletin de
vote c'était il y a 5 ans
utile ah bah moi on m'avait dit de voter
utile du coup c'est ce que j'ai fait on
va peut-être le découvrir à l'antenne
tout de suite voilà pour ce bulletin de
vote qui compte évidemment blanc dans
les yeux urnes Philippe Poutot lui n'y
croit pas du tout à ce vote
utile le candidat du Nouveau parti
anticapitaliste qu'on pourrait surnommer
Joe sans envie ni espoir en deux mots il
n'a pas envie d'être président il sait
qu'il ne va pas gagner et s'il est élu
il va supprimer la fonction
présidentielle mais rassurez-vous il
veut quand même qu'on vote pour lui
on va quand même appeler à voter pour
nous voilà donc soyez pas surpris
[Applaudissements]
malgré toutes les discussions qu'il peut
y avoir en ce moment alors on va pas
dire que nous on est le vote utile on va
pas parler comme ça ça sert à rien on
n'a pas cette prétention là mais on
pense qu'il y a une utilité à voter NPA
et à voter anticapitalistes et c'est ça
qu'on voudrait mettre en avant
Poutou Florent l'ouvrier qui a peu de
choses en commun avec avec notre Donald
Trump ici en France alors les hôtels les
millions et le maquillage orange en
moins j'ai bien sûr nommé Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan alors il est catégorique
l'élection en France est truqué de A à Z
ça vous rappelle peut-être quelqu'un du
lot de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique
autre accusation Emmanuel Macron se sert
de la guerre en Ukraine pour enjamber la
campagne on va l'écouter
en ton prétend pouvoir être président de
la République
on doit avoir la tête froide et ne pas
surfer sur des atrocités de crimes de
guerre comme le fait avec des goûts
Emmanuel Macron
on l'a vu chanter y compris à
l'Assemblée nationale on l'a vu aussi
faire un Paquito au salon de
l'agriculture alors on l'a vu aussi
boire parfois boire aussi et parfois
danser genre Lassalle vous allez
découvrir ces images c'était il y a deux
jours sur un parking avec sa directrice
de campagne sur l'aire de Bella Ciao
alors nouvelle facette de Jean Lassalle
hier soir moins cocasse à Chan on ne va
pas se mentir l'insulte des journalistes
rien que ça en l'occurrence notre
confrère Renault des liens qui l'avait
qualifié dans son édito de complotiste
des champs ça n'est pas très bien passé
regardez
c'est un chien c'est un chien non vous
ne pouvez pas dire ça il n'a pas le
droit
pleine campagne électorale je ne peux
pas dire les choses de comment me
connecter cet homme-là je vous portez
des jugements
traiter quelqu'un de chien quand on est
fils et petit-fils de berger c'est donc
la vie que Jean Lassalle a décidé de
mener elle a promis pendant la campagne
de ressortir le karcher de Nicolas
Sarkozy oui elle a beaucoup misé sur la
sécurité quand les autres candidats ont
beaucoup parlé pouvoir d'achat Valérie
Pécresse devrait conduire et bien le
parti les républicains une troisième
défaite de suite à la présidentielle
dans cette dernière ligne droite elle
est allée en prison l'occasion bien sûr
de tacler une dernière fois Emmanuel
Macron
toute cette chaîne de l'autorité qui va
falloir reconstruire parce
qu'aujourd'hui ben c'est le Waterloo
sécurité d'Emmanuel Macron et on veut
pas que ça continue on veut des
solutions
et puis maintenant un candidat dont on
ne peut pas parler mais seulement
écouter ce soir en raison de cette
fameuse règle de stricte égalité des
temps journalistiques vous avez dit
chronique fourre-tout sont son prénom
c'est Jean-Luc son nom de famille c'est
Mélenchon le suspense est insoutenable
ton vote pour l'avenir en commun au vote
parce qu'on a une conscience sociale
parce qu'on a une conscience humaniste
parce qu'on a une conscience écologiste
parce qu'on a la conscience de
l'existence des biens communs de
l'humanité et que ça fait de nous un peu
des communistes aussi
il nous arrivons au deuxième tour je
vous donne rendez-vous le dimanche
suivant le premier tour sans doute au
stade Charléty et là nous nous
agglomerons
par milliers pour montrer que nous
sommes déterminés à changer le monde
parce que c'est ce que nous ferons si
nous gagnons cette élection
et le communiste dans cette campagne
c'est Fabien Roussel et il est l'une des
révélations de cette campagne oui Fabien
Roussel
pardonnez-moi Joe la punchline voilà
c'est ce que je voulais vous dire on va
voir un florilège de ces petites phrases
qui ont aussi fait la campagne trois et
demi pour cent rendez-vous compte c'est
presque le double de la candidate
socialiste Anne Hidalgo ce score serait
évidemment historique pour le Parti
communiste français florilège tout de
suite un bon vin une bonne viande un bon
fromage pour moi c'est la gastronomie
française le ruissellement de Macron
s'est terminé nous c'est le roussalement
qu'on veut en 2022 pour irriguer
l'économie réelle je savais bien qu'en
suscitant une certaine sympathie et même
une dynamique autour de la campagne que
je porte qu'il y aurait une partie de
ball-trap qui serait ouverte à elle
chante l'international et la
Marseillaise
[Applaudissements]
c'est coco et cocorico
merci beaucoup Florent pauvre
tout de suite la suite de notre série de
portraits oui on parlait hier soir de
Philippe Poutou portrait ce soir de
l'autre candidat de ski c'était à la
présidentielle Nathalie arthavrière
militante anti capitaliste prof
d'écogestion dans un lycée de
Seine-Saint-Denis elle se lance dans la
course pour la troisième fois non pour
gagner mais pour diffuser ses idées son
portrait est signé Natacha Milleret et
Inès au lagaray
occupez le terrain c'est ainsi que
Nathalie Artaud envisage la politique
contrairement aux autres candidats à
l'élection présidentielle la
porte-parole du parti Lutte ouvrière n'a
pas l'ambition de gagner sa troisième
campagne présidentielle elle la voit
comme une tribune pour diffuser ses
idées un appel à la lutte tous ceux qui
sont convaincus que lors de la
mobilisation climatique a sonné il faut
qu'il remette en cause justement les les
lois de cette société capitaliste qui
font qu'il y en a que pour le profit
qu'il y en a que pour les cours
boursiers qui en a que pour ses
multinationales il faut qu'on s'oppose à
cette société à cette économie
capitaliste qui marche sur la tête
renverser le capitalisme c'est son
cheval de bataille et aux manettes il y
a toujours les travailleuses et les
travailleurs
un credo que Nathalie Arthaud répète à
l'envie depuis qu'elle a succédé à
Arlette Laguiller à la tête de Lutte
ouvrière en 2008 sur le caractère sur la
pénicité est-ce que vous ressemble oui
oui sur la pugnacité et c'est sûr sur le
caractère on a certainement des
caractères différents mais c'est pas un
problème
Nathalie Arthaud une personnalité
discrète sur sa vie privée originaire
d'une famille catholique de la Drôme
elle grandit loin du militantisme mais
dans un environnement qui lui apprend à
s'engager pour les autres je veux
dénoncer aussi la responsabilité des
donneurs d'ordre en 1986 alors qu'elle
n'a que 16 ans elle prend conscience de
la famine qui frappe l'Éthiopie révoltée
elle décide de rejoindre les Jeunesses
communistes avant d'adhérer à Lutte
Ouvrière deux ans plus tard
en parallèle de la politique Natalie
Arthaud cultive une autre passion son
métier de professeur d'écogestion elle
en parle et en 2012 lors de sa première
campagne je vis de mon salaire
d'enseignante pour moi la politique soit
en aucun cas une carrière parce que je
milite justement pour que les
travailleurs eux-mêmes collectivement
prennent le pouvoir politique
c'est-à-dire que moi je considère il ne
doit pas y avoir de différence entre le
fait d'être
utile à la société de travailler de
faire tourner la société au jour le jour
et le fait de prendre les décisions elle
a déjà prévu de retrouver ses élèves de
Seine-Saint-Denis le 11 avril au
lendemain du premier tour
on va s'intéresser à présent à votre des
Français de l'étranger oui ils sont
environ 2 millions et demi soit 3% des
votants un électorat pour qu'il la
présidentielle revêtent une importance
particulière malgré la distance qui les
sépare de leur pays d'origine mais la
majorité d'entre eux estiment que leur
situation n'intéresse pas suffisamment
les candidats alors qu'elles sont les
sujets prioritaires qui influenceront
leur vote les 10 et 24 avril exemple à
New York avec ce reportage de Fanny
Chauvin et Jessica le masurier
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue à New York
c'est la ville américaine qui compte le
plus de Français ils sont 35000
habitants ici c'est l'équivalent de la
ville d'Agen et même à distance ils
suivent la campagne présidentielle
[Musique]
et là ça va passer
alors je suis en compagnie d'hélena
linguiste à la retraite et vivant exprès
d'heure de venir traiteur qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de cette campagne
présidentielle on a l'impression qu'elle
a pas vraiment commencé et qu'on va
arriver à l'élection et qui aura pas
vraiment eu de campagne je suis
absolument consternée par cette
implantation de l'extrême droite en
France je trouve que ça monopolise
beaucoup
sur tout ce qui se passe pour ces
élections et ce qu'il y a des thèmes des
sujets sur lesquels vous allez reposer
votre vote l'éducation la santé toutes
ces histoires de contrat social d'acquis
sociaux soit maintenue du point de vue
sociétal je cherche quelqu'un qui est
plutôt à gauche du point de vue
économique peut-être centriste et du
point de vue de la défense ce serait
plutôt peut-être quelqu'un qui serait à
droite peut-être un point qui moi
m'intéresse aussi c'est la position de
la France en ce moment avec la guerre en
Ukraine et je pense que que le rôle de
la France est important là aussi et donc
ça ça m'intéressera pour guider à mon
vote en tant qu'expatrié qu'est-ce que
vous attendez d'un président français la
France elle est peut-être belle et noble
mais elle est pas très entendue donc je
pense que c'est au niveau de maintenant
de l'Europe que l'on peut se faire
entendre donc moi j'attends d'un
président de la République qu'il fasse
tout pour que on arrive à une Europe
fédérale la France dans le monde c'est
plus la bonne échelle moi je sais pour
qui je vais voter alors moi j'ai dit
toujours
[Musique]
alors vous l'avez entendu comment
métropole ici esta français reste
indécis sur leur choix en 2017 c'était
Emmanuel Macron qui était arrivé en tête
au premier tour avec 52% des voix
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui ne
manquez pas notre édition spéciale
consacrée au premier tour de la
présidentielle ce dimanche à partir de
19h heure de Paris spécial présenté par
roselynefeuvre et Raphaël Cannes quand
elles nous on se retrouve lundi prochain
au lendemain du 1er tour de la
présidentielle merci beaucoup à Shrek
c'était donc la dernière émission avant
le premier tour qui aura lieu dimanche
émission qu'on peut retrouver bien sûr
sur les réseaux sociaux et sur notre
site internet
www.france24.com nous on se retrouve
dans quelques instants après une courte
pause pour un nouveau journal Paris
direct continuer rester avec nous